on the mountain 36 year old annabelle
sanchez three and four and nine career
games eight starts
boston meadows swing and a miss
on some cutting action on ebal's 25th k
of the year here's brandon lau the
second baseman
swing and a miss off speed anibal
sanchez
two k's brian yarbrough takes to the
mound for the raise
two on one out for soto runners are
going
pitches up throw is not in time
another double steal for the nance roe
blaze his third
turner his sixth the year when there's
homer strikeouts and walks the gnats
are trying to do it the old-fashioned
way here in the bottom of the first and
i love it
soto with the tapper home on contact
roble scores easily
juan soto is safe at first according to
sean barber
whether he's safe or out the nationals
lead one nothing the rays have
loaded them up here in the second inning
here's michael perez and perez again not
a lot of hits this year but he's come up
with some big ones
swing and a miss on a pitch way outside
sanchez three strikeouts
through two scoreless innings oh what
does brock holt have in mind this time
where's the line drive headed
look at him turn on one it's another
line drive and with two outs he's
definitely thinking too
margo wheels and fires not a good throw
and brock holt is 10 for his last 13
over 400 now as a national two-out
chance for carter kibum to double the
gnats lead
and kibum rams one to left he's going to
get an extra base hit out of this one
then that's lead two nothing
back to back two out doubles trey turner
facing yarbrough out ahead of that one
big hop over sutsugo
it's another extra base hit for trey
turner his 23rd of the year
he's at second base with one out and the
nets
hits tonight all doubles just raining
hits with trey turner
juan soto collected rbi number 27
on the ground ball first in up the
middle
gloved by lau great play but juan beats
it
looking good down the line he is safe
this time
runners in first and third one out curt
gets hit and the bases are loaded big
spot for as dribble cabrera
cabrera lifting one to left turner will
score
easily throw comes into the shortstop
three-nothing nets as the situational
hitting continues to be
very strong joshua went to the gap and
left center first time
right side base hit here comes soto
margot all he can do is hit the cutoff
man over it
short four-nothing nets and josh
harrison
ninth rbi in 18 games that's a nice
piece of hitting
and two out rbi is the story of this one
tonight faces loaded again
sluggers big right-hander makes his
eighth appearance
carter keyboard the hitter and the pitch
swinging a fly ball into left
shallow outgoing adamus and as he
backpedals and makes the catch side
retired three men left slaggers closes
the door
is michael perez the catcher and he
locked him all
up split action there strikeout number
six and vintage johnny bal sanchez so
far in this one
second time through the order rays go
one for nine
with a bun and the first two men are
aboard
and here's g-man choi and it's lined
into right a base head
[Applause]
lau heads to the plate he is
safe with that hand outstretched and he
beats suzuki's tag
so the raids are on the board on the
base hit by choi
and it's 4-1 swaro the new pitcher to
face
yoshi satsugo with two men on
one line to left that ball is headed for
the corner
fair bounding into the corner holt will
have to
go after it rosarina is going to score
it will be second and third and the rays
make it four to two
so the offense coming to life in the
sixth inning
so here's willie he's over one with a
walk two outs with runners at
second and third in a two-run game
and this a wild pinch and a rung's gonna
score
choi comes down from third and moving to
third is
sugo and now it's a one run game and now
the nationals have runners at second and
third for trey turner right off the end
of the bat a cue shot
interesting way to get an rbi and trey
turner gets the nets back up by
two sean doolittle is back on the mound
lefty lefty with austin meadows swing
gonna miss doolittle strikes out
meadows first out seventh inning brandon
lau got their rally started last inning
two in a row on the foul tip a rose
arena
facing him for the first time
popped him up right side right in front
of the dugout
and as drupal cabrera has it and shawn
doolittle
as impressive as he's been all season
one two three go the raise
through the adamas 2-1
out over the plate in the line drive
base hit into left
there's a base set for adamus so the
rays get a base runner in the ninth
inning
so man at first two gone and here is
meadows
swaying in a miss and the nats will
sweep the short two game series
with a team that has the best record in
the american league